so Bonjour - moon hello everyone my name
is Kevin and this is Christophe we both
come from creature which is a French
company that does advertisement
retargeting and we are here to talk to
you about debugging so to give a bit of
context why debugging créteil process
like 200 billion HTTP requests per day
over thousands of servers and when you
work at that scale every tiny random bag
the kind that has less than 1% chance of
happening is absolutely guaranteed to
happen on one of your production servers
and so we are part of the creative
performance team and as such one of our
job is to help developers jagneauxs this
kind of issue when they happen in
production we noticed through our
investigation that we tend to approach
the issues with a particular mindset and
that's what we'd like to share with you
today
so this talk will really focus not on
the tools but rather on the methodology
behind those investigations so I was
talking about the mindset what is it
about it's very simple in fact the first
thing to do when you are faced with a
complex issue is to gather as much data
as you can it's very tempting to jump
directly on your tool and I still do it
from time to time but you really
shouldn't you really should try to
understand as much as the context as you
can and most more importantly you need
to make sure that this is data that you
can trust you have no idea how many
hours we lost investigating stuff based
on forest data
so once you've gathered all the data
that you can the next step is to try to
understand what it means and it's
usually the step where you will start
using debugging tool or profilers to
understand better what it is the goal of
this step is to make a hypothesis a
theory about what is going on with your
application and once you've done that
the last and very important step is to
actually verify very
fiery that what you think is true and
more often than not you will find that
your theory is wrong and it's okay
because in the process you will have
learn more stuff about the issue and so
you can use this new information to go
back to step one and try again and try
again until eventually you managed to
solve the problem so to illustrate this
we took two investigations that are a
real problem that we faced at créteil
and where we are going to tell you about
them so most of our prediction incident
start from the monitoring dashboard so
Christophe could you work through it yes
so we are working in the web-scale team
which is like a team under all the other
application teams and they have their
own graphs and boards related to two
metrics with it to the business and when
they come to us it's usually when there
is a problem at the clr at the runtime
itself so we have this kind of so maybe
I would have to talk like this we have
this kind of board where you can see a
lot of stuff related to a.net okay what
I want to show you is the kind of
thinking we have to keep in our
investigation so we'll take an example
and let's say if we have the the okay so
it's not working but anyway this is the
demo demo good or not with us today but
if you go at the CPU usage level and
let's say we have an increase of the CPU
usage what could be the reason for CPU
usage that's the kind of reasoning you
have to to take so it can be like we
have plenty of exceptions over there so
we need to find a correlation between
this and this one and you could show
have a bunch of requests coming from the
outside world to our servers and so we
can see an increase of requests that
could impact the way the garbage
collection is working in our application
or you can imagine even weirder
explanation that could be you have more
Fred's doing some contention and if you
are using spin locks in the
then we'll have like an increase of CPU
because the code is spinning doing some
wire loop before going into kernel mode
that could be some of the reason when I
left University in 1989 after a degree
in artificial intelligence an expert
system we used to call that kind of
thinking called AB disc in objective
thinking okay so we've been told to add
a cat into our presentation so it went
in the first slide to use birth words I
view the best work so now we can stop
the rila they're real technical a lot of
stuff thank you ok so Wow yeah
real stuff so you manage it myself with
powerpoints yes yes ok so let's start
with the the first example and the first
example start with this part of the of
the board that we are so again remember
the first step is to gather as much
information as you can and you have to
trust in what you are looking at so you
first need to understand what the
contention rate is so the contention
rate is the number of time Fred try to
acquire a resource but another thread is
already having this resource so the
second thread has to wait which is not
good for scalability so once you know
that and if you take a look at this nice
evolution of a time certain at 6 of 15th
of June then you can see that the number
of contention and its I need to write ok
it's not the number it's the it's the
right is drastically increasing all the
time so Kevin what can we say about that
so as I said before before jumping on an
out on your tool try to get as much
information as you can from this so the
first interesting thing about it is that
it started on 15 June so start by
wondering what happened that day in our
case it was easy it was a new release so
it's pretty obvious that we introduced
some kind of regression or so it is that
the contention rate increase over time
so it seems to indicate that we have
some kind of leak and last but not least
not it's not shown here sorry but the
response time is stable which means that
whatever contention we have is probably
happening somewhere in the background
yeah yeah other words the the execution
of the normal workflow would be impacted
so that's about all we can deduce from
this so now we have to try to dig deeper
and we know that it's linked to the
release so the first of your step would
be to check the source code yeah so when
you take a look at the other source code
and there is a new release the easy
stuff to do is to take a look at the
changes that you have added to the new
version so we don't add like tens of
changes but like more than one hundreds
of changes for our release and in our
case it's a it's a kind of the easy case
why because it's really related to a
very specific c-sharp kind of
programming you know we are talking
about threading contentions to think
about using locks maybe we have added
some locks or some some other pattern
that could synchronize the access of a
resource in industry shot code but we
took a look at all the changes and
nothing was really related to this kind
of pattern so what would be the next
step so when you are at this point you
finished with the boring part and you
can start having fun with your with
yours
yes but you should not forget the boring
part okay and we are strong here you
think that you like to be in the
debugger so Kevin like like love love it
but sometimes the abuse step shouldn't
be forgotten okay we want to know more
information about the contention events
in terms of that whenever were in dotnet
whenever two threads are containing your
lock there is an event that is pushed to
etw so if we have a way to listen to
those events we will learn more
information about what's happening so
there are plenty of etw listeners
available but for this precise use case
I like to use JetBrains dot trace
because it display everything in a nice
timeline view that is very easy to use
and so we took a trace on one of the
producer
and when we activate the lock contention
filter then you get all those marks that
remind me of DNA sequencing and they
each indicate one contention event and
when you hover the mouse over them and
try enjoyed working on the screen but
surely you would have a little yeah like
this a little window that tells you what
is the method that triggers the
contention so the problem here is that
we can do nothing with that simply
because we don't know what is supposed
to be here where is the regression so
luckily we already know that we have
some kind of leak and we also know that
it's not impacting the response time so
we can let the server run like that for
a while longer so what we did is we let
the server run overnight and the day
after we took another trace that you
have here and just at a glance you can
see that there is a lot more events and
by comparing the two such traces we can
find that the contention the new
contention is caused by the fire method
in the timer queue timer class so now we
know where it comes from
okay so we know where it comes from but
it begs new question so time our queue
timer seems rates into timers but how
can the timer even close contention so
Christophe can you go up yes saying that
yes first time I have to go to do that
you know in a conference
ok so this is the kind of step where you
usually happen what I mean by that is
that when you are investigating an
application the bits your application so
you know the source code and you have
the source code but maybe you are using
sir parties or maybe you are using
the.net framework and in that case here
the timer queue timer it's just an app
annotation detail of how the dotnet
framework is managing the timer that
your code is creating so you need to
take a look at how it's implementing so
you can use the website provided by
Microsoft the reference sources or the
soups of
net which are very good but I usually
prefer to use a decompiler
so this is the D compare I'm using use
the one that you want and I want to take
a look at how the construction of a
timer as an impact so here the
construction of the of a timer you pass
the callback you want the timer to call
when it ticks if you want to pass a
state to pass the state and you tell him
when it should tick and if there is any
kind of repetition you pass the period
easy so this code end up calling timer
set up with the same parameter and in
the timer set up you see that the timer
creates a timer holder and the timer
order will get an instance of the timer
to time a class the one that we've seen
in the in the dot trace solve DNA is
something that you love so much
so let's take a look at what the timer
to timer is doing
remember we passed the callback the
state the due time and the period if
there is any repetition so we create a
time a few timer and it's really really
simple the time accurate timer is like a
poco that keeps all the value that you
have given to the creation of your timer
and that's pretty much it so if we take
a look at the timer all their class it's
even simpler and just keep track of the
timer to China then you would say why
would you do that
because it's only purpose is to ensure
that if unfortunately you are working
with not perfect developers they might
forget to dispose the timer and in that
case this class implements a fertilizer
and the finalizer will kicks in after a
garbage collection
when the timer order is no more
reference and it will close the timer
okay so we've seen the timer the timer
queue timer the timer older and oh yes
we need to take a look at the fire
method maybe and this is one thing that
is
with us just waiting for you to to
remind me so remember we are looking for
the source of a contention contention is
there is one thread trying to acquire
the same lock as another thread which
already has the lock so here you can see
we have two locks so we have one lock
before calling the callback and one
other lock after having called the codec
so okay so now we know that fire can
cause contention but it's a lot of
information all at once so can you make
a summary we can so it's it it's only
code C sharp code so let's draw a
picture when I'm creating a timer under
the hood I get another instance of an
object of the timer all the class that
is referenced by an M underscore timer
field from the timer object that time
holder referenced the timer to timer
through an ml dose go of timer shield
and the timer cue timer are stored in a
linked list by the best class library of
the.net framework and it's kept by the
time our cue object in the PCL so that
way we have a list of timers that are
maintained in memory great so now we
understand how timers work we're still
wondering why we are using so many
timers well we have some contention so
there are two possibilities either we
are using a lot of timers oh we are
using just a few timer that are taking a
lot and so to find out what is happening
it is time to use my favorite debugging
tool that is windbg and so for that we
capture a memory dump on the projection
server and then if we open it with
windbg we can run the dump that command
which gives you a summary of all the
objects in memory how many of you are
using windbg
that's a lot 12 okay 12 okay good okay
so windbg
let you open a memory dump and we can
take a look at what's inside the
the address space and all the objects
that have mentioned in the co2 that we
will be doing with script equipment so
once you have exactly the command you
can search the timeout queue timer
inside yeah because it's reports console
F that's one of the best feature of the
tool I mean the one who has laughing the
one who are using a windy VG timer timer
service focus we see that we have 14,000
instances of timer timer so just like
before you can eject to conclusion after
seeing that number you need to know what
is a normal number for your application
and from my experience in Krita our
applications tend to use about two
thousand timers which is already a lot
but here clearly we have like twelve
thousand timers too many that's why I
like the world clearly because when I
enjoy in créteil in the first
investigation and I end up in this kind
of doors and I look at the the number
and I see what you have more than 2,000
timers we have a bug there we have a bug
that I will tell you and Kevin say no no
we need a few hundreds for our Kefka
subsystem and a few other hundreds for
this other subsystem and so it might be
funny when I'm telling the story but
it's very important that when you are
doing an investigation you know both the
source code as I have explained earlier
but also the numbers the the way your
application is supposed to behave
compared to the load for example because
in that case this kind of number would
mean a lot for you it means like it's
red and it's blinking if you don't know
these numbers you will just pass through
okay so then you can dump your
individual sorry instances of timer to
see what they are doing for that you can
use Adam Hipp - MC command we executed
beforehand because it is a 20 20
gigabytes sumo Adam so on this text it
takes a bit of time and so if we click
on the first one to inspect it we see
all the fields that crystal told us
about yeah but we are interested in the
time I'll call back
do you know what is this time are doing
so if you click on it thank you we have
an instance of delegate so with method
pointer supposedly you can find the
actual method at this card but I know no
easy way with windbg to convert this
value into meaningful name but
fortunately we have something into the
target field which means that this is an
instance method and just knowing the
type that contains the method could give
us enough information so if we look we
now know that whenever this timer ticks
it calls a callback on meta metric and
we cannot deduce anything yet so if we
take another timeout so for instance
take the last one we don't have to
scroll all the way just like before we
look at the timer call back then at the
target and we see that this one timer is
used by a cap card matching that
accumulator so now that we know how to
retrieve the information from the timer
we just have to use that for each and
every of the 14,000 timers in the in the
list so Christopher please like this guy
so yeah sure I will I will do that
here you are facing the kind of issue
that we are often facing at creature
with this huge huge memory dump of the
application with a lot of objects inside
and it's another kind of scalability
okay we're talking about runtime
scalability for your application but
when you are debugging also you don't
want to waste your time clicking on
stuff and just taking notes or using
like an Excel spreadsheet and please so
here we need to kind of automate the
some part of the of the search so for
that you could use windbg with this new
version you have a scripting engine
based on JavaScript but I was I won't
use it throwing about that expectation
the work but I prefer to use C shop so
Microsoft is providing a nugget package
called CLR MD and we see on our MD you
are able to do the exact same thing that
I have done in windbg meaning that you
can follow up the links going into all
the instances and I will show you that
it's it's really really simple
so I have written a tiny
application so is it big enough the food
a little bit bigger no answer so it's
it's big enough so in this library you
start with a data target - data target
type represent either a memory dump or a
running application okay you can you can
do both you can connect to a running
live application or a memory dump in my
case it's it's a memory region then from
the data target you ask for the a
version of sorry you ask for the running
CLR inside this process once you get the
runtime you can ask for the heap managed
by the garbage collector in that
application and then from the hip you
iterate on each and every instance of
object that is told by the garbage
collector so once you get an address
because everything ends up on an address
I know that the the the.net language for
this is a reference okay but in the API
it's an address a reference is an
address that can change its value but
it's an address sorry I have to maybe
quicker sorry about that so once you get
the address you can ask for its type so
which type of object is behind the
address that you've taken from the from
the it managed by the garbage collector
and here we are uninteresting in the
timer callback because it is what Kevin
did by hand asked me to do by hand and
once I get unsure that it's the kind of
object that I'm interested in then I'm
asking for the definition of its target
field if you have done some reflection
in dotnet this is very very close to
what you are doing in reflection you ask
for the definition of a type the
definition of a field and then using
that definition you ask for the value
stored in the underscore target field of
the object pointed to by the address and
again I'm interesting in the time
because this is what I'm looking for I
want to count all the type in the
instance of type that are referenced by
the target
adding them into a list and I'm doing
some very nice link code that I really
love by grouping and sorting so what I'm
running this I should get at the top the
instance of so I get 12,000 instances of
Metro metric so in short we enumerated
all the time our callbacks just to see
what they tick for yes so I run it
before because it's 16 gigs on it yeah
so we see that we have 12,000 instances
of matrix code code at meta metric and
this is a number of time of outstanding
timers that we have so it's a good
coincidence so at that point it's safe
to conclude that this is causing our
program so the next step is to try
understand what is a meta metric yeah so
real fast we well nobody actually use
meta metric it is an internal type
instead the developer are using a
wrapper that is named meta
it keeps a reference to the meta metric
to GE get meta property the meta metric
as an underscore time a field which
contains the timer and whenever the time
at 6 it calls a method on the meta
metric so now we have to understand what
is keeping all of our min symmetric
object alive and I can really think of
two possibilities either we have a lot
of major instances and we are still
referencing them somewhere or we forget
to disperse the timers and they keep our
meta metric objects alive ok so if you
remember what I've said about the
implementation inside the base class
library the timer or the class would be
responsible for releasing the timer if
we are forgotten so I would start by
looking at the the meter potatoes so the
good thing about working with an expert
see that he can save you some time by
providing his variable inside so now
that we know that it's almost certain
that we are leaking metal objects we can
go back to
windbg to check that
and the first thing we could do is to
try and find what is referencing our mid
symmetric object so we could use a
Jessie root command for that but it only
display one path to a root and not all
the paths and so we don't want
necessarily see all the referencing
pointing to meta metric so instead I
like to use another windbg extension
which name is SOS X and he defines a ref
command which displays the references
going to an object and it's an it's also
faster it's also faster and so if we
call it on our meta metric we see that
it is only referenced by a time I'll
call back and not by the meta object so
it seems to indicate that Chris off
might be wrong on this point but I have
a hard time believing it so we're just
going to double check if Christophe is
right then we should have pretty much as
many meter and stands as meta metric
that's something we can check easily so
we go back to the top and the dope it -
start and you're looking for the meta
meta meta matrix and here if you can
scroll just know okay we can see that we
have 800 instances there are not enough
even do we have - a thousand
metal-matrix
so it seems free two points there were a
mistake of yours but let's triple check
because I can abduct Christophe thank
you very much and especially in front of
the audience yeah very much so
another way to verify what you said
would be to iterate on all the timers
and we're the ones that are using by
whether using meta metrics sorry and
check is a I've enclosed okay so I'm
going to no no no I'm gonna sell R&D to
do though yeah but I want to be faster
this time so I like sir I'm Z a lot but
the problem with that is that whenever
you want to check something you have
to live windbg study just video create a
new project import the Nugget package
write all the boilerplate code script
your thing executed then go back to in
dbg I feel like this is a break in the
workflow and also use waste of time so I
wrote this extension for windbg which
allow you to write c-sharp code directly
from
windbg so what is what Kevin did it
integrated into the UI itself but in
addition it's also I've written all the
boilerplate code that I've been using
you know getting the memory dump for
example here it's windbg that got that
and so when you start to write with his
extension you see that directly you have
the this eep object so you directly have
the hip and you can start to write some
code so here you want me to explain what
you're doing ok so is using an extension
method called get proxies and the get
coxey's will return the list of all the
objects for this type so it's much
easier than my loop my big loop when I
an emeritus here I just asked for a
certain type if it's the time I'll call
back then I want to ensure that the
underscore target field points to a
metal matrix remember we are only
interested in the metal metric case and
so if this is the case oh yeah so I love
this kind of code so if you can try to
follow what is written so the the
callback as underscore target and the
other screw target which point to the
timer that points to what is the name of
the type of this one older time oq timer
and timer and consult yeah I don't
remember too many timers so you can see
that in under one minute we just wrote
what Christophe did in his long Visual
Studio program so it can save you a lot
of time in yeah I can't even I can give
you more reason to use this kind of code
which is that this is C sharp this is
not reflection like kind of code so it's
much
more easy to write and the extension
that Calvin did which is integrated
inside windbg is also available in your
own tool like what I've written it's a
it's a döner MD extension okay I'm not
going to either couch it live because it
takes minutes and we are way late but
spoiler issue that Christophe is wrong
in that one so none of the timer has
been closed okay clearly you don't know
how final is the sports Christopher okay
so I don't know if Anna's also remember
we have three different steps in the
kind of investigation and the last one
is the verified so we have some
assumptions Lex from impetuses and you
need to confront the Portage's with the
fact when there is something not
matching like here because I know
definitely know how it's working
I'm expecting that it shouldn't be like
this so I've written a repro of the kind
of code that you are describing so here
I have an instance of meta metric that
reference the timer and when I'm
creating a meta metric I create a timer
and I'm expecting that on the console I
would see a tick tick tick every one
second and for the testing framework in
the main I'm creating a meter over there
which is the one written by this
function and then I'm calling the
garbage collector a garbage collector
saying that please could you bet some
room for me
so since I'm not referencing this
instance anywhere in the code I'm
expecting that the garbage collector
will get rid of the instance and after
the garbage collection happens the
finality of Fred will kicks in and see
that this object as a finalizer
will call the fertilizer and we'd close
the timer so I'm expecting to see tick
tick tick tick and when I'm press enter
no Morty do you agree I don't like of
mine really control f5 and tick tick
tick tick
okay okay okay so maybe you're right
like this time yeah this time but then
can you explain to me what's going on
with the a petition okay so if we go
back to the picture because in the damn
clearly the term the timer's are not
reference yes and they are not dispersed
yes so let's add the big picture with
all the elements that we've seen in in
the investigation right now so this is
the critical view of the problem so we
have a matter that reference a meta
metric that reference a timer and the
timer will call a callback of Metro
metric but here in the picture we also
need to add the base class library if
you of the implementation so over timer
referencing a timer order and the timer
order is referencing a timer to timer
are we on that yeah what we've seen
first in windbg is that the number of
matter over there is not enough to
explain between eight hundred and twelve
thousand it called reference or the
timer cutomers
and we have also seen with my tiny demo
that's my understanding of how the
finalizer is working for a timer seems
to be right so what's going on so what's
going on why isn't the finally they're
being executed okay maybe it's because
you didn't listen to me when I'm
explaining will explain how the timer
implementation I'm pretty sure some of
you have remember the fact that the VCL
is keeping track of all the time of you
timer through the timer cue object and
the name of the field is s on the score
Q and S stands for static okay nice you
just explain why the time of Q timer are
still alive but it still doesn't explain
why the finite others I'm kicking okay
so when the garbage collector is trying
to figure out if an object should be
kept in memory what it does it does a
first fast of what is called marking
marking in started from all the routes
could be on the fret stack could be a
static could be in the registers and it
goes down following all the fields of
all these objects and mark them one
after
the other so if we follow what it will
be doing it will be doing here saying
there is a reference here market go
there market market and so at the end of
the day the timer order will be
recursively marked as been used so the
garbage collector will see that there is
a route down to the timer order so he
won't be able to let the Parizeau be
executed okay so it makes sense make
sense but then what is the point of the
time I hold on why did it work in your
demo because I was cheating I was
cheating just for you just for you not
for you just for the audience okay
nothing against you really so what's the
difference between my code and the code
that we have in production
it's a tiny detail but if you take a
look at this function this call to the
console it's a static code what I mean
by the statical I mean that the compiler
will see that we are calling a static
function that so it doesn't need to
provide the disease implicit parameter
as the eden para first parameter of the
function so there is no such link here
there is no link to the Metro metric so
okay okay so this concludes in this case
whatever you have will learn here sorry
we've learned a few things the first
thing is that you can't trust Christophe
to make a repro the second thing is that
in our code the meter type did not
implement a disposable where that's our
mistake so developer couldn't call
dispose on it and it turned out that
because of this reference cycle the
final user of the timer cannot kick in
and so our timers are immortal and so
during the lifetime of the application
we keep allocating more timers and they
generate contention whenever beta and
this lead to this progressive increase
of contention and they're not sorry to
interrupt but when when Kevin was
making fun of my ability to reproduce
it's something very important you know
when you're trying to reproduce the
problem try to be in the in the real
condition okay okay so what was this
thing again I think you were saying that
we've done some of the the way we are
okay thank you so why did you happen
with that version in particular it's
because before then we always used
matter in singleton class and this was a
first version of the application where
we used a matter in a transient type and
that's why that's why it's revealed the
leak and that's why we couldn't see it
just looking at other changes the code
changes and so the fix has been
obviously to implement a disposable in
meta and also because it was a lot of
work to change all the code that calls
matter and we wanted a quick mitigation
so we also implemented a finally in meta
which is outside of the reference cycle
and so this final is a work properly and
mitigating the issue like I explained
yeah and so through this investigation
we've seen this mindset I was talking
about
whenever facing a complex issue that you
don't understand first start by
gathering as much data as you can make
sure this is data that you can trust
then try to put that data into context
use tools to dig deeper and try to
elaborate a theory about what is going
on and then don't forget to verify what
you think and then try again and again
until you manage to solve the problem so
this was a fairly straightforward case I
think many people here knew about this
kind of gotcha
with timers so we prepare a second case
which is going to be a tiny bit trickier
so crystal can you introduce it yes so
in
in that particular case we've seen a
brutal increase of the number of
exceptions that are managed by our
application what I mean by that is if
you have a try/catch block and there is
an exception that is thrown inside the
try block it's called an exception that
you can manage and it's the what we call
the third chance exception and your code
catch the exception usually make a log
and that's it but this has true impact
on performance so we are monitoring this
number and here you see that we started
from something very low I can't say it's
zero because it ended up at almost 1
million exceptions a minute yeah so
that's like twenty second twenty
thousand per second so so I guess that
the application would be on its knees so
well surprisingly the application was
still running fine and answering to
requests just as normal in fact it took
us nearly 24 hours to notice the problem
so monitoring great great monitoring
except except a slight increase in CPU
there was nothing wrong with the
application okay so what would be the
the next step remember we are in a in a
real world application so we we expect
to have logs in our application and as I
as I said at the beginning when you are
doing your try-catch block in the cache
block it's a good practice to lock the
exception that your could have seen in
the in the cache block so I'm expecting
that we we have killed our logging
system and it's just swarmed by all the
exceptions you can export in here so
there was nothing in drugs so maybe it
means that we forgot to lock the
interception is the catch block I don't
know finger pointing we said about
developers so when you are in that stage
you are like okay we have millions of
exceptions but I don't know which
exceptions so how could you do that I
know a trick which is using a tool from
sysinternals and this is the tool that
are usually using to take a memory
snapshot of an application and get a
memory dump file and this tool is called
product but you can also use program to
list to view in the console all the
exception that are thrown in your code
and end up into a catch block and for
that you are using this common line
which is - e for exception one for
fortunes exception and the minus F is
for the filter and you give nothing for
a filter and if you run this with the
process ID of your faulting application
then you will see the name of the type
of all the exception that after all so
it is very important to mention that in
this talk we are describing what we did
back then - for this investigation and
not what you should do you shouldn't use
program to try the exception instead you
should use etw events which much less
intrusive but back then we didn't know
that so we use program intended that
program was so intrusive that after
attaching to the process we would see a
three for exception and then it will
slow down the process so much that it
wouldn't be able to do anything more but
it helped us to see that the exceptions
run our sweat about exceptions that is
mean that we have some code that are
calling fredita bollocks
so I checked the source code looking
specifically for fed that abort car and
this is not a joke it was really like
that I found a call to spread out abort
but it was removed from the codebase one
week before the release sure
and so in fact it was so crazy that I
actually went to a production server and
decompile just some live there to make
sure that the code word on there and
indeed each word on there okay so this
is something very important remember
when you are gathering information for
understanding what's going on you need
to trust what you are looking at so here
we have a kind of coincidence that going
into a server or asking our customers to
decompile the binary the
the Assembly to ensure that the code
that is running is really what you think
is running it's really really important
so don't be scared there is nothing
wrong doing that and actually we were
talking with some guys at Douglas team
team at Microsoft and they were
wondering why we would ever use a
decompiler since we have the source code
of the net core and the source code of
our application and the reason is simply
that this is the only way to be
absolutely certain of that you know what
you are indicating yeah anyway so
nothing is called sweat dot abort but to
get more information I attached a remote
debugger and try to see what was going
on and I noticed that from time to time
in between the straight about exception
we will have a cannot unload abdomen
exception and this is very interesting
because this application is using
asp.net and asp.net is known to unload
the abdomen when you make a change to a
configuration file and whenever you
unload an abdomen it upwards all those
threads in the domain so it seems like a
good community so it just means that
somebody is editing the configuration
file on the server and saving twenty
thousand times
configuration file I don't you have this
habit that you press ctrl s every time
you type a word no 20 I mean yes but not
that fast okay okay it must be something
different right still looking with with
the debugger I noticed something weird
is that the three report exception was
always happening with the same car stack
so if you think about it it makes kind
of sense because if we have a bug you
can expect we just have one bug that
caused the same effect so yeah I'd agree
on that because if you are aborting
spreads and you have really no reason to
have the upward Oh curing every time at
the exact same point in the course pack
and so since I was wondering about that
I checked the shred ID and the straight
abort exception is always happening in
the same spread always the same thread
or by the same twenty thousand times
yeah but if you if you check the code
it's a source code it makes sense I mean
it gets pretty obvious when you see it
so this is the curse tack where the
thread about exception was happening and
so we have a metal inside we have an
infinite loop okay and inside we do some
processing in fact we are uploading a
file to a remote server and then we
sleep for 15 minutes so why are we not
using a timer here I don't know maybe
the developer was afraid of leaking
timers probably probably probably but
the important part here is that it's
happening in the try-catch block and
it's written purposefully in such a way
that if an error happened we retry
immediately that's because we expect to
have some transient Network here or
during the operating and we just want to
retry so now imagine this code is
running then there is a change in the
configuration file so asp.net abort the
spread but so it's throw an exception we
get into the cache block but then we
exit and then we keep going on the while
loop so the abdomen tries to abort the
spread again so it show a new exception
which we are inside this try block so we
catch it so we stay in the loop so the
abdomen try to abort the thread and I
think you get the idea
write down your very nice story because
I like very nice story so so it could be
good except that we are talking about
the thread about exception and it is not
how or fair about exception is working
yeah so so so if I can just resume what
you were saying ok we are in there in a
in an infinite loop there is a try-catch
block and in the middle there is an an
exception okay so the exception is
caught in the catch block it's a thread
about exception so we do whatever we
want with the X here and then we exactly
what I want
we log with what we want but the
difference between this kind of
exception and the rest of the exception
is that after the last execution of your
code the runtime will ensure that the
front about exception is
thrown and we from outside of your tribe
lock so you will just have like an
infinite loop that stopped at the first
iteration so you think that it is going
to be strong only one time yes so this
is a very nice story Christophe you know
I I respect you a lot
you're very wise man an expert you
graduate in 1989 you are a master of
objective thinking but in this case just
look at the facts okay just the fact we
have 20,000 exception per second they
are all happening on the same course tag
here yeah
and always with the same thread ID and
so just looking at the fact and quitting
somebody more famous than me he's
staying with his world that you are
wrong Christopher I like this I like
this so again remember we have the three
steps and here we are at the end of the
step two we mean that we have facts we
have stuff that we can see and we we
know how it's supposed to behave so we
have to verify if the facts are wrong or
if the guy would say it's better like
this is wrong so I will double check
that again like the satire you remember
ok finalizer
so if I'm going to not here here and I
think I have something that looks like
your nice method so I have a method with
an infinite loop I have a try-catch
block and in the cache block I'm just
pushing to the console the name of the
exception so you are logging the
exception so I'm logging the exception I
was not okay I'm logging the a the
exception so how can I test that I'm
creating a thread that will be cooling
my infinite loop method then I'm
starting the thread and when I'm pushing
the press the button I will about the
thread yeah I never do that with one
yeah yeah don't don't do that just for
for the audience so if I'm running this
I'm expecting to see press 'enter to
terminate the the thread working I am
pressing just one line we
thread about exceptions and I'm telling
you that just from the fact we already
know that your console is going to be
fluid advice for that but let us let
steel John speed up is a judge here I'm
running the code I have a present to
terminate working on so it's very
important in this job to learn from your
mistakes yes and remember the mistake I
did earlier it was a trusting Christophe
to make a repro and so if we're not
always okay don't throw is my fault if
we check the project and we see that
it's running in debug mode it's very
important to do your repo in the release
mode because it changed a lot of thing
triggers a lot of optimization and this
can change the behavior of your PMI my
mistake so this time okay I run it run
it working and so another part that is
important in this job is not giving up
okay once again Christophe is trying to
trick you because he's running the
project is any CPU and if you are
running with the default settings then
it will run your program in 32 bits and
I now on our server it is running 64-bit
you're right
lots of things change sorry we are using
pointers that have double the size and
so maybe it's overflowing some kind of
data structure and you never know
sure sure sure of the flowing of the
Ponyo Ponyo yes so what I'm supposed to
I'm just running pointer size right just
sighs now so it can't be convicted it
can be the poet so here again we have a
conflict between different view of the
same reality so well later in reality
and your view yes
okay okay so my reality is supposed to
be like this when you are calling thread
that abort it's a kind of a synchronous
call what I mean by a synchronous I mean
that the call itself will set a flag on
the thread objects and in the flow of
execution of this Fred
when enrich what we call safe place by
the just-in-time compiler then it will
throw the thread about exceptions to be
sure that it's in the right thread that
the fan about exception will be thrown
and then this code check that if you are
in a try-catch block at the end of the
catch block in ensure that the exception
sorry the exception yeah so - take again
will be reef route but outside of any
try block that's my view of the reality
who is writing the code that is
generated by the just-in-time compiler
okay so that you're interesting because
another thing that changed when we are
running 64-bit with that framework is
that you will be using a rigid which is
the Nuge it kind of new you and who say
new say bugs and so maybe we've run into
a bug in such it and there is one way to
find out
okay is if you open the application
configuration file okay and so time for
some live coding
you could add a runtime mud run time
mode I'm too old for that
run time node and here you can add a key
which is use legacy JIT like like this
no I see it I said so use it like this
what
oh you mean this so sorry huge legacy
jeez I mean there is no auto-completion
so just get last legacy get like this oh
yes okay so he's doing that because
because we gave the same torque at a dot
next no it was a data developer days and
he did a typo on on purpose here and so
it didn't work and I was on a stage
wondering why he wasn't working so now
I'm careful okay front I'll enable
equals first please with with upper case
come on well force Oh true yeah first
sure because it's usually guess he so
I'm expecting true in your team oh no ya
[Laughter]
don't
don't thank me okay it's just saving the
demos so what I'm doing this I'm telling
at the wrong time that I want to use the
the old interesting time compiler when
the application would be running so we
will be in release 64-bit with the long
pointers yeah and with the old
just-in-time compiler yeah run it work
again just one line and so we've
confirmed that there is a bug in digit
so the first thing we did is reporting
reporting it to Microsoft because we are
good citizens
yeah so they told us that they would not
fix it
but they're they have good reason they
have good reason
it's just that apparently it's very
complex fix it happened de Burgh happen
only on very specific card and it's only
under that framework because you don't
have a shredder board on the net core
and new aboard no problem so to fix to
fix it in our code base
what we did is adding another catch
block where we specifically catch those
read about exception and then we we
threw it ourself so that's some conduct
I never imagined I would be I would be
writing ok
so through this case we illustrated the
importance of verifying your your
assumption which may be which may be
incorrect and in fact remember how
nothing was logged it was especially
hard to find the code of the problem
because we didn't show it but in this
code there is actually some logging
going on in the catch block but it turns
out that whenever you entered the
abdomen you abort the thread and sew the
thread of the a synchronous logger was
being aborted and that's why we didn't
get any log yeah but if you go with the
right mindset and method that method
Akali confirm each of your assumption
sooner or later you will get to the root
of the problem of a letter ok ok so we
also wanted to show you that sometimes
you need to have your own tool like what
I've did which the set of Salah Ramsay
some some time you need to extend the
tool that you are using like what Kevin
did with our windbg because it just
helped you to scale in your
investigation so don't be scared don't
be scared you can do it and it will save
you a lot of time I think the the most
important type of as you've seen is like
you never
ever assume that you know what's going
on because if what you see is not like
what the model that you have in mind you
need to verify verify always and more or
further not you will see that even with
a wise and a long career you might be
wrong okay so we are also we have
written some blog post so if you want to
dig a little bit further inside the
tooling inside the kind of the
investigation you just look for the
creature labs blog series and you can
touch us on Twitter if you have any
question and I would like to thank you
for your passions so I know this is the
last session of the day before the the
craziness will start so we we have three
minutes but since it's the last session
if you want to ask more questions we are
free to answer no question oh yeah sorry
what's my favorite decompiler I'm old
enough to remember the reflector time so
I used to use reflector before it was no
more reflector but I'm using il spy you
can use what is it so personally well
there is dot peek from jet brain that I
like a lot to navigate to cut that it's
painfully slow to open so if the jet
brain guy in the room please optimize
that thing also there is the inspire
which is well not as practical than dot
peak but it allows us to live debug a
process which is incredible yes you can
set breakpoints and everything you don't
have you don't need to have the source
code it's much more than just a compiler
James 5d ends by DN sorry for the French
accents DN spy sorry just below the
light
okay so the question was why did you
decide to use like a remote debugger
instead of having a custom build with
more instrumentation inside I think you
can answer this one where I can give you
answer the first one is time this is
well this is what this is Malik or
forcefully abort six but we have two
cases here with 92 for the leak it's
small enough that you wouldn't see it on
on a deaf computer so it's really hard
to instrument and you don't even know
where to instrument actually yes
for the stray about succession it's even
worse since we didn't even know what
triggers it
in fact so I mentioned that the abdomen
is unloaded when you change a
configuration file and the configuration
file was changed by the app deploy your
application that deploys a file in
production and so that's something that
is very hard to reproduce and that's why
as much as possible we prefer to get
information directly from the memory
dump because you know that the issue is
there if we cannot figure it out then we
add more traces to the code and yes and
other reason is also that some time
you can't reproduce the problem we have
we are talking about thousands of
servers in six data centers like this so
when when we have one that is
misbehaving and we try to keep it for a
short period of time but with because we
have the repro over there and if we
change a little bit the code add some
logs add some stuff you might change the
way the threads are behaving so maybe it
will work that's another reason
yes yeah yeah exactly
yeah any other question
yes how do we test the curd before
putting it on production sir we test a
lot we test a lot so we have a lot of
unit tests in the code so it's even so
we have the unit test we have the tests
that run at the build then we have some
dedicated server on which we test
several applications because we have
like microservices communicating to each
other so we have the dish first I mean
the last step before going to a
production we have three products offers
and if you if you just miss the the case
where the installer application changed
the configuration file then you just
don't miss it
because we are doing the test in a
question of hours not in a crucial knows
of days and maybe in this environment we
don't deploy until the end of the test
so but for those specific issues we
don't test it I mean I don't know how to
tell that No
so how much time then did it take days
please two to three days yeah for those
investigation yeah they took took about
the same time I think yeah well then we
have an initiation that took weeks yes
we have longer investigation because
here it's like kind of simple because we
showed you the metric that was
interesting and then the part of the
code and then because we with large
memory dump or so it takes a lot of time
that's why we try to automate if you if
you look for for the blog and on my name
also on github and convinced name you
will find all the source code of the
extension you will also find the source
code of application that are using CLR
MD that you could use to make your own
tool to automate all the process it's
really really simple believe me it's
really really simple so try to automate
your own investigation it will save you
a lot of time so for example for the
timer we were doing a lot of stuff like
manually and then we wrote our own
windbg extension and we just added a new
command called timer information and so
now we just bang TI and we get the list
of all the timers with all the callbacks
so we learn from what we are
experiencing and we are trying to to
minimize the number of time that we are
spending on a manual process
[Applause]